hey guys today i'm going to share ideas
on lighting for males
my name is gerry guinness i'm a wedding
portrait and fashion photographer i've
been photographing for almost 30 years
and teaching for 20.
in this tutorial we're going to teach
you how to light men
and how to go from this to this by the
way i have this amazing course the
portrait photography quick start
click on the link and download it for
free enjoy
all right guys so i'm here actually
photographing in full sun i have no fear
in photographing in full sun but it's
quite tough
you can see jacob's actually already
struggling to actually even look
at what's going on right now so i'm
gonna basically ask him to just close
his eyes just relax a little bit
and um on the count of three look at the
camera one
two three okay so we've got a shot so
he's struggling
that's okay some people will be more
sensitive to light than others that's
okay
now some of us may have the idea of
putting
our male subjects and female for that
matter actually in open
shade but let's have a look at what that
looks like okay so come nice and close
to me
okay just about there okay the lighting
is flat makes his skin look really good
but there's really no depth and drama
but i'll take it anyway let's have a
look
all right close your eyes a second one
two open
okay so we've got that one all right
so on the other hand we might actually
shoot in the opposite way
so now we've got open shade that's
reflecting back off the sun
now this might be a great location but
it's actually my garage
but the lighting is going to be a little
different still okay just there
ready eyes of me
okay and he's struggling still okay so
many of us attempted to actually always
backlight and there's not a problem with
that but
what you have to understand is that the
light coming from behind
um will never give us also a good
quality of light from the front unless
it's being reflected by something or
we're adding in a strobe or something to
that to that effect
but if we're tempted to do it the easy
way
simply just backlight everybody then
we're going to get a shot like this so
he's looking at me
great i get the shot so you'll see the
difference between the
sunlight shot the backlit sunshot
then we've got the open shade and then
we've got the open shade in a different
area and you can sort of see that
it's okay but i wouldn't really call
that lighting it's just sort of like
well
stand there and let's hope for the best
the idea is that
we want to create mood and depth and
dimension and character
and say something about who we're
photographing and that's where these
lighting tips that we're going to share
are going to work for you so we're in my
garage my glorified studio here we have
the garage door open and we have natural
light basically coming through here
illuminating jacob now this could be
likened to whether it's actually a
window light
whether it is in fact a garage door
being open whether it's a strobe
doesn't really matter we've got a big
light source illuminating our guy
jacob and now we actually need to learn
what are we looking for when we're
photographing a guy what is considered
more masculine
what's considered a bit softer and
feminine well it really depends on what
we're trying to say
and that's just it if i was to be asked
well jerry what is
good lighting mean i believe good
lighting is either flattering and or it
helps communicate the message
that the artist is trying to convey to
the viewer in this case you
so right now we have jacob sort of
facing the camera perfectly
we have light coming from one side and
basically what we're getting right now
in my camera as you can basically see
it's a very masculine quality of light
now what do i mean
when i say masculine masculine means
it's a bit harder it's a bit contrastier
in this case we have one one side of his
face being lit the other side is can
complete shadow
so if for example we had a female face
or a female form
with this kind of lighting and maybe we
didn't have so delicate features
on that female face what happens is if
you use this what i call
contrast the masculine light well that
would actually
not be very nice and not be very
flattering on that female form
in like manner when we go back to the
male face this guy
he's a good looking dude no problem and
it doesn't matter how good looking
or how challenging your subjects are
it's really up to you and i to bring out
the best in our subjects
so right now jacob is facing the camera
as we said i'll get his hands in his
pockets we're going to basically be
focusing on head and shoulders for the
moment
and right now i'm just going to get you
to hang your body a little bit more
forward and then chin down a little bit
eyes at me so no smile for this one just
passive really cool
and basically the way he's looking at me
right now it's quite
passive which is what i asked for but it
almost looks like he's just looking into
nowhere
i find that when you're photographing
anyone for that matter if you want to
get a bit of mystery in the eyes
uh for decades i've been saying give me
a little hint of a squint that lit
that's it
got a bit of brow pressure there which
looks really cool hold it there
all right so as you can see we just have
a very
masculine quality of light one direction
of light we've got no hair light
and it looks really really cool now do i
turn his body
and his face towards the light and if so
what does it do
so remember we have one direction of
light he's looking into the camera one
side of the face is being lit
one side is not i'll often get asked the
question jerry when i'm
lighting a guy when i turn his face
towards the light when do i
stop well let's try this so what i want
you to do mate is i want you to turn
your face this way
and turn okay so we'll come to what
this lighting situation is all about in
a moment but what i want you to do
is we're starting on the light side of
your face so
i can see more skin than i can see
shadow so more
of your face is in light than it is in
shadow what i want to do now is i'm
going to get to
the top of your head towards the light
stop there and now i want you to turn
your face
keep on turning keep on turning stop now
as you can see when i'm actually looking
at him i've turned his face
until the eye socket that's closest to
the camera which now has become
his left eye or our camera right i
stop his face until his complete eye
socket is completely lit
now you might say why are you so
particular by saying eye socket
well if he turns his nose this way so
turn turns stop
now that shadow is cutting into his eye
depending on
the face and how attractive the face is
then it depends on how far we can get
away with it my suggestion is either get
the eye completely lit
or not so before if you remember
we had his face half lit and half knot
in this case
i start with his face away from the
light let's do that and now jacob turn
your face towards the light very slowly
slow
slow follow by hand follow follow
and now i can just see the corner of his
eye completely
lit that's where i stop now that makes
me shoot on the shadow side of his face
often referred to as the short side or
the narrow side or i call it the sexy
side
and then we just simply shoot in that
way perfect
so if you look at the difference we've
got straight
um a photograph with split lighting
lighting on one side not the other
then we're actually shooting him on the
short side of the face what we'll do
is i'll actually just shoot you with a
passive look so turn your face this way
again
turn your face that way good good hold
it there
perfect so as you can see i've turned
his face towards the light until his
this eye socket that was in shadow is
completely lit
why do i stop when the eye socket is lit
because now i get that beautiful depth
and dimension of his cheekbone and his
jawline
and life is good so now that i'm
shooting him on the shadow side of the
face
would this shot look good shooting him
on the light side of his face
often referred to as the broadside i
actually quite like it for guys
especially with the slim face like
jacobs so what we're going to do now is
we tilt your face
we are going to do split lighting but
we're going to do
split broad we're shooting with one side
of your face being lit
but you're turning your face this way
and then our eyes back at me you can see
how the quality of light is a little bit
different on his face
okay so chin a little bit more down down
this way good eyes at me
really cool hold it there mate hold it
hint of a squint awesome hold it
very cool so you can sort of see how
this shot looks really cool being the
broadside it makes him look
fuller in the cheeks but it brings out a
lot of character
he gets away with it because he's got a
slim face if we go back to the other one
that looks really cool that short side
of the face and then of course you've
got the split side
now what happens if we photographing him
front on with a good quality of light
well that'll be less descriptive his
skin will look even
even smoother than it already does
because he's young he's a young guy
but you will see the difference as we do
it so now what i've done is i've
actually placed myself
where the light is coming from so in
this case the garage door being open
this could very much be the same as me
standing in front of a window
and positioning my subject right over
here and then
facing facing him with the light and of
course my camera
now you'll notice that it's softer on
the skin great it's less descriptive
but depending on the nature of what you
want this might be what you need for
example if you're photographing maybe
parents or grandparents with aging or
mature skin this might be the direction
that you want to go for
if you want to actually photograph
texture and depth and dimension
then lighting coming from the side as we
basically did before
that will bring out more shadows which
will actually give you that drama
right now there's no drama we're just
doing clean portraits
looking at the camera let's just do that
right now okay eyes with me mate just
passive is called good hold it
good nice clean portrait it's okay it's
nice
um and i guess that's all it is it's
nice and it's
safe for me even more important than
lighting is actually shadows in this
case
i don't get any shadows really
whatsoever maybe a little bit underneath
this jawline because the light's sort of
coming from
from up high let's see what happens when
he turns his face one way or the other
so let's just turn your face a little
bit this way turn
now you can see how very subtly he
actually turned his face to the
background
and the background is quite dark so it
cut away light
that is actually going to look really
good for him because now we're adding
depth and dimension where we
we didn't normally if he for example was
in open shade
open shade is in the shade of a building
or a house and
he was facing outwards towards a light
source
it would be no different than seeing a
result like we just had
a second ago which you can see right
here but if we turn his face to
something dark
like a wall or even tilting his face
more to the ground
the ground and or the wall cuts away the
light adding a little bit of shadow
by simply angling his face let's do it
the other way and see what happens
okay so turn your face that way good
turn that's it just there
awesome man hold it there
good so we got a similar result
why because actually we're shooting in
the inside the garage here my exposure
is set for the quality of light coming
through and then all of this
there's the ambient light it's not
really giving it much light anyway
so i quite like the fact that if we have
to photograph front on or if we're
tempted to
simply angling the face one way or the
other against a darker object
then that's going to give us a little
bit of depth dimension and form so for
example
if you're photographing someone with a
fuller face with bad
bad skin maybe a bit of acne this might
be the great way to do it because you're
shooting with
softer light as in light coming from
where the direction of the lens
and the camera is the photographer light
is flooding onto the subject
therefore it's less descriptive we're
not describing
shape and we get beautiful skin but now
when we tilt his face we add a little
bit of shadow so for the plus size guy
for example
we're cutting away light in some ways
by turning his face but we're adding the
softness of the light coming through
which is probably a good balance of that
particular subject matter
now let's change our lighting situation
and add just
an extra element of light and see what
we get
so i'm going to move in this direction
and jacob i'm going to get you to stand
right there for me
let's have a look lighting on you very
nice
and let's adjust and play
so what i'm doing here guys is i'm
actually uh going to use
two ice lights for those of you don't
know i'm the inventor of the ice light
and i'm
very very proud to say that sort of
in most photographers camera bags which
is really cool
and what we're doing here is we're going
to use one ice light
to first of all to separate him from the
background
and then we're going to also use a light
on the background
to just add a little bit of drama and
depth as well for that really
masculine quality of light this
so barn doors are basically a way of
cutting away light so think of it like
this
light travels in straight lines so if
your light source is over here it's
going to travel in straight lines and
it's going to illuminate
anything and it's basically path now
what i want to do is i want to create a
beam of light on that background
to basically bring the viewer's eye in
this case you the viewer's eye
right into my subject matter um and it's
gonna look really cool
if i just put the light on the
background the whole background will be
lit but i want this beam of light
leading your eye into the actual
photograph so i'll be using this in a
moment
first of all i'm going to photograph a
portrait of jacob just with the natural
light coming through again that could
just be a big soft box that could be a
big window light
it could be a garage door that's open
doesn't really matter we just need a
direction of light that's actually
illuminating
um our subjects and then of course we're
going to refine and chop and change and
get different looks
and really there's when i say there's no
right or wrong yes you can be more
flattering yes you can be more
purposeful
but more importantly you got to do what
suits what you're trying to say
in this case i just want to make him
look freaking really cool simple as that
so actually let's get jacob in the
darkness
and you'll see the quality of light
change on him
as he comes closer to the light so let's
just start you over this way mate
okay so he's basically in the shadows
all right so now
as we bring him closer just walk really
slowly slowly nice and slow
towards the window or in this case the
garage door of course
stop there perfect so he's wearing black
he's also a brunette so he's just sort
of blending into the background
personally i think that's okay i quite
like
dramatic sort of shots like that i don't
feel like i always have to have a light
separating him from the background
but it's pretty cool too as well so
let's try a few different ways
so first we'll do a
shot let me have a look here now what we
can see here is
there's split lighting but there's a
little bit of light touching the other
side of his face
consistent with what you've probably
heard called rembrandt lighting
rembrandt lighting is either when either
one eye or both eyes are in shadow
and it's considered a very masculine
quality of light so turn your face this
way
actually turn your shoulders towards the
light it's a really good tip as well
guys that whenever you're photographing
a guy
if you point his body towards the light
source it's going to make him look
bigger and broader
whereas with a female form you turn the
body away from the light source
and the face back in but for the guys
turn the body towards the light
and and the face towards the light as
well bigger and broader
we turn his face like we said before
until
the eye socket that was not lit is
completely lit
so that's it turn this way good eyes at
me really cool
hold it there okay so as you can see
there now
it's nicely lit the background's pretty
dark
it works well but let's add some depth
and dimension and now we're going to add
a continuous light in this case the ice
light
as a little bit of an edge light it's
going to hit a bit of his jaw it's going
to
hit a little bit of his hair and let's
see what happens from this particular
angle i draw
imaginary line from this light source to
his face
if this light can hit his nose it's
going to look weird so what i do is
i position myself where i can just miss
his nose
and then i bring the light source a
little bit higher
i'm going to turn it on and that's going
to separate him from the background
and then just add that little cool
professional touch
okay let's have a look yeah that looks
really good
it's cool because it adds a little bit
of a hair light to the equation as well
cool man hold it there so this this case
just looking
passive good hold it let's look at the
difference now
so you've got no hair light no edge
light with
and i think we can actually honestly say
that looking at this this
looks like the more professional kind of
quality of light you wouldn't get this
from an amateur just wouldn't happen
but this is the cool thing you might not
have an ice light you might not have a
big strobe
all this has to be is some light source
in this case a window
or a garage door being open this could
also be another window over here so
remember if you've ever got a
if you ever walk into an environment
where there's two windows put your
subject in the corner
turn their face the light open up the
blinds behind them and now you've got
this beautiful
uh hair and edge light and then you've
got this sort of main light source as
well
now this could even be a an iphone light
for it for all you know so
let's leave that there so now what i'm
going to do is i'm going to come nice
and close to this background
turn this light on
you see how it gives us a really really
cool beam
so i want that separating him even
further from the background but leading
your eye
into the shot so i'm bringing this light
closer to the background so i
basically see more contrast i see more
an obvious highlight and more of an
obvious shadow
it's going to be out of focus but we
will see the difference that's really
important
actually quite like that little beam of
light it's got that very he's got a very
how do i say a really sort of cool
hollywood kind of a look
and i quite like the fact that the
lights coming from the top and instead
of beaming down almost like a spotlight
and then you've got that uh that light
hitting his hair and
hitting his jawline which looks really
cool and
i'm going to bring this even closer to
him
so i can get a bit more contrast again
draw an imaginary light between him and
his nose
make sure it doesn't touch it otherwise
you'll see the light on top of his nose
so it's going to look a bit weird
and now so lean forward turn your face
this way
good eyes back at me all right chin down
a little bit
good hold it there chill down more chin
down more
good hold it man hold it good
don't move just like that hold it
and there you have a huge difference
between the three
in fact let's do it live so you can see
it okay so stay there for me don't move
an inch
so we're going to turn these lights off
so now inside inside my camera
you can see that the lights falling on
nicely let's start from the beginning
turn your face away so now we turn the
face to a point
until his eye socket right there tilt
turn stop eyes back at me good
okay so now we've got his face nicely
lit it's not touching his ear
notice too that we can't see his left
ear
watch this turn your face this way more
stop
you see how his left ear is popping out
it can look a little bit weird
either i get the ear all in or all out
in this case all out stop
it's less distracting so keep on looking
at the camera watch what happens
we turn this light on boom separates him
from the background
and then even further adding depth and
dimension we add
this light that gives us
a really cool feel as well
and now we add a little bit of finesse
to the to the
overall expression so give me a little
hint of a squint and looking out this
way
yeah that's awesome dude hold it there
hold it
perfect i love the fact that your eye
leads in from the light from the
background
leads into the subject of course now the
light the second light the ice light
that's closest to him separates him from
the background catch lights in the eyes
we've got shadow depth and dimension and
form it's a really cool way of actually
photographing a guy
so remember guys lighting doesn't have
to be that difficult start with one
light simply turn the face towards a
light source until both eyes
are completely lit now you know you've
got the right light on them
make sure the actual catch lights in the
eyes are in the 10 or 2 o'clock position
that's when you know you've got a good
direction of light and all you have to
do is simply just actually add
the expression whether it's actually a
little hint of a squint looking away
looking down
having some fun whatever it may be but
every good
photograph starts with really beautiful
lighting that's flattering to the
subject
and meaningful and purposeful for who
you're photographing so remember
photographing men doesn't have to be
difficult
practice practice practice
thank you so much for watching hope you
liked the video and if so please give me
a thumbs up don't forget to subscribe
and hit the bell to get notifications
for future videos please leave a comment
so we can connect and i can answer any
of your questions
see you in the next episode and don't
forget you don't have to be the best you
simply have to be better than last week
we'll see you soon
you